hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe heute ein italienisches rezept für
euch einen kuchen rezept und zwar ist
die frau von einem kuss italienerin die
dani und jetzt mir vorgeschlagen kommst
erleben was italienisches zur osterzeit
und zwar ist es der passieren
napolitaner ich hoffe ich hab's prüften
sie ausgesprochen das ist so ein kuchen
den gibt's in italien zur osterzeit aber
auch das ganze jahr über in der bäckerei
also das ist wirklich eine spezialität
dort und ich habe den auch so noch nie
gegessen muss ich sagen und zwar ist es
ein feiner mürbeteig da ist eine creme
drin mit ricotta und mit weizen und das
ist auch ganz frisch und fruchtig durch
die zitrone und die orangenschale und
einfach das ganze aroma und ich zeige
euch jetzt wie man diese diesen kuchen
herstellt und man brauche ein paar
zutaten dafür ist es auch ein bisschen
aufwendig aber es ist nicht schwierig
also man muss sich schon ein bisschen
zeit einplanen weil man eben auch alles
selber machen möchte und ja aber es ist
handwerklich jetzt nicht schwierig und
wir legen jetzt einfach mal direkt los
zuerst muss ich jetzt einen teil der
füllung vorbereiten und zwar braucht man
dafür eigentlich so eine italienische
spezialität das heißt karl otto und zwar
ist das weizen der vorher gekocht wird
und den gibt's zum beispiel in
italienischen supermärkten bereits zu
kaufen also in dosen oder in kleinen
gläsern
in italien gibt es auch überall und der
wird dafür verwendet alternativ kann man
dafür aber auch wenn man denn nicht
bekommt hier brauchen benutzen da hab
ich jetzt verkaufen in fein und zwar
gibt es den in verschiedenen als tipp 2
1 mittel und groß und jetzt habe ich da
300 gramm und dem 600 gramm wasser und
kaufen das den weizen oder gerste kanada
sind enthüllt geschält und poliert und
die muss ich jetzt kurz vor kochen und
es dazu etwa eine halbe stunde bis die
dann weich sind
also ich das wasser noch mittagsruhe
kocht das ganze gut auf und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich dann schon mal die
zutaten für den mürbeteig richten
ihr müsst jetzt aufpassen dass die
flüssigkeit nicht zu schnell verdunstet
das heißt auch mittlere stufe stellen
und bei bedarf einfach noch ein bisschen
wasser zufügen
und wenn die dann weich sind sind sie
fertig wir müssen einfach mal ein
bisschen probieren
jetzt bereite ich den teig so und zwar
ist es ein ganz toller feinripp teig das
ist der 124 teig das heißt ich habe 300
gramm mehl 150 km kalte butter 75 gramm
zucker eine prise salz etwas wenn
elektra und 1 1
ich nehme jetzt hier ein ganzes und
nicht nur geld über meinen anderen
beteiligen weil ich einfach möchte dass
das ein bisschen kompakter ist und
besser zusammen hält es gebe ich zuerst
die butter in einen mixer also könnte
soll mit den händen verkneten oder mit
dem teenie tage dann kommt da dazu kam
mit rein natürliches einmal kurz durch
mehr zu
dann kommt da direkt das eingetreten mit
prise salz und natürlich vanille extrakt
jetzt gebe ich schon mal einen teil vom
mehl mit dazu um der rest kommt gleich
zehn grad rein
das restliche wichtig jetzt mal mit den
händen ein das mache ich es hier einmal
kurz auf der arbeitsfläche
m
den teig gebe ich jetzt in eine form und
ich drücke ihnen immer ganz gerne ein
bisschen flach dann wird er nämlich
schneller kalt jetzt denke ich ihnen ab
und kann in der zwischenzeit die füllung
fertig vorbereitet
stimmt spitze die zeitfrage sind jetzt
etwas abgekühlt und ich hab leider
vergessen dass die ja noch im wasser mit
den quellen und dass ich das natürlich
dann alles etwas vergrößert und an
volumen zunimmt
deswegen habe ich jetzt davon ein
bisschen was abgewogen er im rezept im
block werde ich euch dann noch mal ganz
genau beschreiben als ihr braucht nur
100 gramm davon nicht 300 und hier bis
350 gramm davon abgewogen
dann brauche ich noch 100 milliliter mit
30 gramm butter eine rio zitrone und
drei eier die drei eier habe ich jetzt
aufgeteilt in eiweiß und eigelb und ein
eigelb das brauche ich nicht für die
füllung sondern später zum bestreichen
ich habe ich 120 gramm zucker 250 gramm
reporter käse ein teelöffel sind 50
gramm habe ich jetzt gemischt zitronat
und orangeat und etwas vanille extrakt
zuerst nehme ich jetzt die graupen die
vertrauten und gibt sie noch mal in
einen topf und zwar habe ich dir so
vorbereitet so wie man eben auf diesen
italienischen gries bekommt also diesen
weizen gries den bekommt man auch so
vorgekommen
das muss man jetzt aber nochmal acht
übrig die muss man jetzt noch mal mit
etwas milch aufkochen
da kommt auch ein stück butter mit rein
und zitronenschalen ab blieb aber ich
koche das ist schon mal kurz auf da ist
ganz wichtig dass in bio zitrone nimmt
und man könnte jetzt natürlich auch
sagen man kann die per glauben direkt
mit der menschen mit wasser aufkochen
aber das würde ich nicht machen ich bin
zwar erst mit wasser aufkochen und
danach mit der milch denn sobald man
mich im kopf hat kann bis er am
topfboden immer anbrennen und deswegen
immer erst wasser und später damit
minister muss man nicht sagt aufpassen
jetzt lasse ich es kurz aufkochen und
dann etwa 10
lang ziehen
ich habe die masse wirklich nur kurz
aufkochen lassen und da den herd wieder
abgestellt und dann so etwa zehn minuten
quellen lassen
jetzt kann ich ihnen derzeit schon mal
den teig ausrollen das muss jetzt
eigentlich alles so bisschen parallel
auch laufen denn so war ich den teig
ausgerollt habe kann ich dann die
füllung wieder weitermachen also diesem
moment ein bisschen hin und her aber es
ist logisch so datei ist jetzt auch
schön kalt den rolle jetzt etwa zwei bis
drei millimeter dünn aus
soll ich den teig auf den ausbau stab
aus und habe jetzt hier bereits eine tat
form gerichtet mit hebe boden ist die
games schon eingefettet und jetzt 25 cm
im durchmesser
ganz vorsichtig legt den teig darüber
wenn der teig kreis ist es okay wenn er
nicht reist wieder dran flicken
dem restlichen teig hebe ich jetzt noch
auf dann brauche ich später nämlich noch
obendrauf
jetzt kann ich die führung weiter machen
und schlage tessmann sieht die eiweiße
zu steifem schnee
da kommt eine prise salz mit rein
sobald der schnee fest ist kommt noch
die hälfte des zugangs mit dazu und dann
ruhig noch mal kurz weiter
als nächstes zerkleinern ich jetzt noch
die früchte also auch angeschaut und
zitronat die kamera theoretisch auch
selber machen aber das dauert vier bis
sechs wochen
also musst du lange ziehen lassen und
deswegen nehme ich die jetzt lieber so
fertig
den eischnee stell ich kurz zur seite
habe jedoch eine zweite schüssel da
kommen die zwei gelbe reden gemeinsam
mit dem rekorder käse dem zu krass
zimtpulver und dem wein wächst reckt und
es wird kurz verrührt
dann drehe ich da jetzt noch die per
draußen ein bisschen jetzt von der
konsistenz her nicht mehr so klebrig
sondern eher cremig und natürlich auch
gut abgekühlt zitronat und orangeat kann
ich auch direkt mit rein geben
normalerweise kommt hier sogar noch ein
bisschen orangenblüten wasser mit rein
das gibt dem ganzen noch mal ein richtig
tolles aroma das habe ich jetzt aber
leider nicht da aber ich habe auch die
zitronenschale mit drin und das zitronat
und auch an scheidung sollte so schön
frisch genug schmecken
jetzt kann ich hier nur noch den
eischnee unterheben und dann ist die
füllung fertig
jetzt kann ich die füllung direkt auf
den tat boden streichen
und den restlichen teig den rolle ich
jetzt noch aus und dann wird er in
streifen geschnitten und wiesen gitter
darüber gelegt
ich
das eigelb habe ich jetzt verrührt und
kann die teig streifen dort bestreichen
ich bin
jetzt wieder kuchen im vorgeheizten ofen
bei 180 grad ober unterhitze dafür etwa
60 minuten gebacken
danach las ich ihn komplett abkühlen
oder probieren wir ihnen zu sein
der kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt ist aber
noch ein bisschen lauwarm also ganz kalt
ist noch nicht kalt schmeckt er noch mal
viel viel besser
wer möchte kann ihn zu lassen oder ihr
stritten ein bisschen süßen schnee oben
drauf diego ich hab mir gesagt glauben
87 grad hat nein da ist schon fast kalt
er hat schon also über eine stunde
durfte er schon richtig toll ich liebe
italienisches gebiet und es ist halt
wirklich so richtig typisch italienisch
den updike ist schön knackig also ich
denke du wirst das leben das ist zwar
eine tat am stopp der makler nur
herzhafte das macht die katzen bittet er
wenig es nicht ich freue mich jetzt vom
kuchen haben hier in der mitte
diese tolle schicht mit dem weißen weil
er sehr saftige ja es ist ein bisschen
erinnert diese füllung so an milchreis
man kann auch wenn man diese gerade du
solche kommt und eigentlich auch keine
milch naja wenn man diese gruppen also
diese perle kraut nicht bekommt kann man
auch reis dafür nehmen stattdessen mit
daran probieren ist es passiert mit drin
und zitrone und orange also eigentlich
muss es mögen sie doch aus
und also ich finde sich was ganz anderes
ich habe die masse vollen euro probiert
jetzt hat jeder seine gedanken also ok
richtig lecker beschreibt nicht also
bietet nicht weniger zucker machen auf
jeweils nicht weniger zucker sich ein
ist erinnert mich etwas
dann waren sie schon mal gegessen habe
ich sagen ist das saftig sehr fruchtig
genau dieses zitronat jagt man aber
merkt man nicht so stickig haus weil
viele mögen das nehme ich nicht so
dieser großen stückchen deswegen habe
ich die auch vorher durch einen mixer
gegeben damit sie eben ganz klein sind
und dann merkt muss eben nicht alles
machen könnte ich könnte zum nächsten
das ist ja wirklich auch sagen also
falls er dieses rezept nach machen wollt
dann geht auf sex - lockte das stets
noch mal ganz genau und vielleicht habt
ihr auch spezialitäten die ihr kennt
oder die aus dem urlaub kennt die es
selber zu hause mit eurer familie
zubereitet
dann dürft ihr mir da gerne die rezepte
zukommen lassen ich schaue mir an und
macht sie gerne für euch nach süd aus
ich glaube so essen ja wandertag ein
schluckauf mehr alles klar viel spaß
beim nachbacken und wir sehen uns das
nächste mal
bis dann tschüss sich den schluckauf vi
schlafen
ja